mas o teste não é o rio mais belo do
mundo porque o rio mais bela do mundo
passa na minha aldeia né
eu sei que tenha na grafos sul mas as
cachoeiras mais belas do mundo cair na
minha aldeia e põe no e ali
nesse cenário de cachoeiras de pastagens
uma praça uma igreja ao cenário bucólico
zona rural
eu nasci de uma família grande de 11
filhos e meus ancestrais foram todos
todos os homens do campo e ali começou
realmente a minha história eu preciso
aqui destacar um desse personagem desses
meus ancestrais que foi importante
demais para moldar o meu bairro e foi
minha avó com quem não tive muito
contato na infância e na adolescência
sobre tudo mas minha avó dona lila era
conhecida na região de põe é uma como a
mulher altruísta solidária e que levava
a mantimentos na garupa de um animal de
um cavalo tudo que sua fazenda produzir
fazendo dela do meu avô para alimentar a
fome alimentar pessoas carentes e
socorrer essas pessoas famintas meu
irmão economia inclusive costuma dizer
que foi ela que inventou a cesta básica
no brasil e eu tinha seis anos e aprendi
com ela fazer essas visitas com ela e um
menino de seis anos eu aprendi a me
aproximei e conhece a dor da fome porque
na zona rural de itabira naquela época
anos 70
existia fome sempre existiu
no brasil também ali por incrível que
pareça mesmo campo existir fogo e ela me
deu esse conhecimento essa sensibilidade
a dona lia também é uma grande contadora
de histórias
ela contava tantas histórias e inventava
quantas histórias que ali também
despertou o meu interesse pelo
conhecimento pela narrativa
talvez por isso me tornei jornalista
anos depois no período que não existia
internet televisão muito pouco
praticamente o contato com a imaginação
umas histórias eram poucos livros também
mas com ele nesse personagem de 100 mil
acessos estral rural
aos nove anos subir na carroceria de uma
picape
emprestado pelo dono da venda o meu pai
pra carregar os 11 eles não a mudança
foi tabira porque o seu propósito era
estudar proporcionar uma melhor escola
dos seus filhos
cheguei em tavira também início da
década de 70 setenta e poucos pujança
econômica milagre econômico no brasil
a mineradora o xanthi produzindo grande
produção de minério ônibus tempo todo
carregando trabalhadores operários 24
horas de explosões de dinamites mais um
grande movimento de trabalhadores e de
produção
foi um choque cultural que sair daquela
zona rural e foi estudar em escola
pública numa jornais anj aprendendo um
pouco a acontecer com esse universo
muito diferente
o universo da mineração muito diferente
daquele que eu vivia então aos 12
eu virei pro meu pai fazendeiro homem do
campo e disse eu preciso eu quero
trabalhar
ele não entendeu por que é propósito da
mudança foi tavira é estudar
os filhos ele pro via os filhos não
precisava
não era uma necessidade familiar que os
filhos trabalhassem
ele perguntou por que você quer
trabalhar no entanto eu não soube
responder
realmente eu não tive resposta naquele
momento mas ele consentiu que eu fosse
trabalhar e arrumar um emprego na
farmácia do seu délcio na periferia de
itabira no alto dos peritos e ali foi
trabalhar dos 12 aos 15 anos e tive o
meu segundo contato depois do contato
com a fome através da minha vó eu tive
um segundo contato com uma segunda forma
talvez a segunda mais dolorosa de zero
humana ea enfermidade trabalhando na
farmácia eu pude ter contato com pessoas
doentes o tempo todo e ali eu aprendi a
fazer injeções aprendi a aviar as
receitas das letras difíceis dos médicos
e pude também desenvolver o meu primeiro
trabalho voluntário porque muitos idosos
oriundos não conseguiam ir até a
farmácia para tomar suas injeções
diárias eu estudava de manhã trabalhava
tarde e as noites eu ia visitá los
aplicar as suas injeções levar
medicamentos levar histórias começava
minhas narrativas porque quem está numa
cama doente também quer um pouco de
carinho é um pouco de palavra e isso
tudo eu conseguir fazer com que me
despertasse um pouco o sentimento e essa
aproximação essa consciência de
comunidade ea consciência de estar perto
de uma dor muito grande intimidade ele
venha à memória a um pensamento final do
stive jogos quando ainda muito doente e
muito rico quando ele disse que você
pode pagar às pessoas para fazer tudo
pra você em seu lugar
mas você não pode pagar uma pessoa para
deitar no do hospital em seu lugar para
atravessar uma doença em seu lugar a
doença sua você tem que ir com ela até o
final e depois daquilo aos 15 o meu pai
fazendeiro ainda fazendeiro e poema mas
empreendedor
ele se tornou sócio até europa o hotel
tinha um pouco surpresa e tavira esse
era um hotel importante que tinha na
cidade sair da farmácia e fui trabalhar
no hotel não como gerente como podia se
imaginar do filho do sócio mas eu fui
como carregador de malas um apontador
dos funcionários e bateu me deu uma
possibilidade de encontrar pessoas
eu carreguei muitas malas de pessoas
mineração pujante a companhia recebendo
gente do mundo inteiro recebi pessoas do
mundo inteiro ali carreguei malas
pessoas internacionais
o hotel me deu esta essa possibilidade
de abrir um pouco a minha imaginação
o universo da outros universos além do
universo de itabira e eu me aproximei
muito da cultura grana de artistas da
música das artes cênicas ali fui estudar
música na banda euterpe e ainda jogar
futebol fazer tudo aquilo que um garoto
normal fazia e ainda trabalhava sul de
música e me aproximei de de pessoas o
jornalismo ele já me encantava um pouco
era um é uma fase que o cometa itabirano
o jornal alternativo é de itabira fazer
muito sucesso promon escrever para o
jornal eu li aquilo com com um interesse
enorme tudo aquilo e etc
tenho que ir embora está vira pra
continuar meus estudos para fazer
jornalismo né e aquilo me veio eu o
pensamento maior
ou melhor o maior ensinamento além dos
poemas maior ensinamento drumond me
trouxe e modéstia à parte eu quis ir
fazer como drumond fez em sua aldeia e
seja internacional
essa é uma fase de bom rapaz do tolstoi
mas o drumond exercitou essa esse
pensamento dos toy
então esse foi um grande ensinamento
leon tolstoi e diz rodeia seja
internacional
eu fui então ser buscar esses novos
universos em belo horizonte onde
terminei do fui pra faculdade estudar
jornalismo
continuei trabalhando continue estudando
depois do jornalismo eu fui e aí eu
entendi que a universidade era um espaço
fundamental
entendi muito bem o porquê meu pai
colocou os seus filhos na carroceria da
caminhonete e os trouxe playtime estudar
mais e não ficar na zona rural porque a
universidade é o grande celeiro do
pensamento da pesquisa da reflexão da
crítica é fundamental
eu corri atrás disso exerci o meu
projecto universitário
trabalhei como jornalista do the vistas
nacionais e regionais até me tornar um
executivo e fazer a opção para a
comunicação empresarial e trabalhar e
trabalhar nessa essa grande empresa por
onde ninguém por muito tempo como na
área de comunicação trabalhando a
comunicação as narrativas durante o
jornalismo trabalhei muitas narrativas
da sociedade e da economia da cultura da
da violência na grande cidade e na
empresa existia narrativa de produto de
marketing não é a narrativa de uma
companhia de empresa que precisava de se
inserir com a sociedade
mas os tempos eram outros
naquele momento internet basicamente se
iniciava
não existe meio ainda era tudo muito
rudimentar a forma de comunicação era
muito difícil basicamente feito através
da imprensa convencional mas ali eu pude
entender que a empresa precisava de se
inserir na sociedade de outra forma eu
pude trazer essa contribuição e tive
sorte de ter dirigentes colegas na época
e apostaram nesta neste modelo este
pensamento e permitiu que eu pudesse
avançar um pouco mais na linha de
comunicação de uma empresa pudesse
promover a inserção mais absoluta
possível da empresa com a comunidade
empresa aumente social ela não pode mais
se resumir a gerar impostos e gerar
empregos e gerar lucros para o acionista
ela precisa de deixar um legado muito
mais importante para a sociedade e esse
eu busquei isso da empresa criei
imediatamente um projeto social chamado
árvore da vida onde empresa iniciou o
relacionamento com a comunidade do
jardim teresópolis em betim que era
então a comunidade mais violenta de
minas gerais com 200 homicídios por ano
dez anos depois o índice de homicídio
dessa comunidade tinha se reduzido pela
metade e se empoderar ão nós criamos
projetos com as crianças com os pais em
cooperativas com as crianças em educação
e com os jovens em capacitação
profissional com eles ele inclusive
trabalhar minha própria indústria nesse
aspecto
ali a eu ganhei por conta disso a
diretoria de sustentabilidade é um
aspecto uma coisa muito mais ampla e
depois
talvez os dirigentes da empresa não
sabia porque estava me dando a diretoria
de sustentabilidade está rodando a
diretoria de sustentabilidade eu sabia
por que por causa da minha vó bia e
poema quando ela me aproximou da fome
por causa da fumaça do seu bolso pode me
trouxe lei de enfermidade e por conta da
minha a das linhas narrativas
eu aprendi ao longo do tempo e precisava
de promover uma nova narrativa para
empresa que o encontro dela uma
sociedade a quebra de um muro entre
comunidade e entre empresa e
sustentabilidade para mim é adquirir a
plenitude de do trabalho a plenitude do
trabalho é você criar valor para si
mesmo e também para o outro então a
sustentabilidade para mim é saber olhar
para o outro
naquele momento há pouco tempo eu
entendi
eu encontrei a resposta que eu precisava
dar pro meu pai quando aos 12 anos ele
perguntou por que trabalhar e agora esse
microfone do ted eu posso responder o
meu pai está em outra dimensão que não
está aqui mas que trouxe para estudar me
deu essa oportunidade eu digo pra ele e
meu pai eu quis trabalhar aos 12 anos e
intuitivamente porque eu queria aprender
mais
eu queria não ter limites para poder
enxergar o outro e dá a entender que a
plenitude do meu trabalho era poder
chegar à outra outra pessoa obrigado